[Music]
Hey Oh eight-eight hey brother sleep
match back for the 2019 assays beat all
the trip and my cousin Percy
yeah put the sleep mask in the bars come
out like some bars outside and the bar
is out what I'm in this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
you tripping if you ain't thing I'm
spitting and I'm saying same [ __ ] but I
say it all rhythm and I come through the
[ __ ] then you know I said show yep get
settle show my [ __ ] you want my
merged oh I say no [ __ ] you want
the merch give me the [ __ ] bar bug
I'll hop in a totally glorify hey that's
pretty hot man
welcome back sleep mask sleep man oh man
oh [ __ ] it mask oh I'm kind of good
sleep mask wise adult you trying to get
sleep mask sponsor get asleep what's up
from the first episode this is a little
heavy I got double sleep mask on right
now so we stopped at CVS I lost my
original sleep mask from episode 60 so I
I said you know what I started to get
angry
until I realized we're in a major city
and then CVS is a Walgreens around and I
can get a sleep mask within five minutes
so we went to one two minutes away and I
felt good about getting a sleep mask I
didn't feel great about asking what a
sleep mask where for whatever reason hey
small [ __ ] I got to get through so we
found them and I got the sad enjoy I got
this didn't realize I had eyes in it but
luckily I had to send cuz I like you
know I like buying a lot of [ __ ] that
can't break me I was talking with Percy
about this earlier I like going into you
know a 7-eleven a gas station yeah look
at that snack so looking at items are
saying nothing in here can destroy me
fine
when I steal playing it safe try to keep
it under 40 bucks I just want to say man
like this this look is awesome right
you're like the MF DOOM a comedy proper
introduction to my cousin Percy Percy
Percy you watch a last name on this [ __ ]
Percy it's all good yeah Percy we'll all
right yeah hilarious yeah youyou should
just take away and it's not I'm not this
I don't do this to disrespect black
people okay I do this to you you know
they have some restaurants where you uh
you they is all is blacked out in the
restaurant and you they serve you food
and so you just kind of rely I obviously
rely your sense of taste and everything
but they that's part of the experience
so I'm just trying to make it more of an
experience for myself and just see how
my brain operates when I'm not looking
at stuff okay yeah yeah what if we what
if we did a podcast once like just in a
pitch-black room yeah that'd be weird
but I think I guess maybe do you think
it'd make people more honest for summary
I don't know I mean that's definitely a
audio-only one
yeah no no no cuz there's night-vision
cameras oh so we can see just look
awkward is [ __ ] like trying to look at
each other and talk but no one's making
eye contact and it'll be like this weird
we should definitely do that you know
it's almost like you're putting the mask
on the audience exactly no no the mask
on us but the audience cuz I said that's
it we should get on that
yeah Percy Percy when we meet just meet
me yeah family they've heard us talk
about you before yeah mention on a pass
multiple times right sort of you know in
the pocket you like a figure of it a
little bit you're a character in our
world since 1984 84 I was born in 83 so
you were born in 81 right yeah so it
probably meant late 30 36 years yeah
yeah Percy I think honestly you're the
first family member of Hannibal's I've
met yeah before the other ones okay
yeah that's out kicking it yeah I think
yeah I think you were the first ride
from what I remember yeah yeah I was
always like I [ __ ] with that guy that
guy's awesome he knows how to party
yeah yeah almost a little too much like
last night
Michael I respect the fact that I can
catch it before everybody else does
yeah you I saw you going dark yeah yeah
yeah I was in the conversation and my
head was just doing this but my ears had
turned off yeah it conversation it's
like I got a call I saw you fade no no
it was tough it was tough that word
faded makes sense because I saw you
fading from you were fading yeah I
wouldn't expect it to sit on me as heavy
as it did like I mean yes when you eat
Weed Man it's not like smoking where you
just you could just splash water cold
water and you've made some food and nap
it off like it's like it's you suck it
was pleasant at first no because it was
like checking in on me yeah and then
wait it was like I'm here now yeah we're
in this night together yeah I went
outside I walked around the venue at
least three times trying let that cold
air just bring me back we'd you can't
just shake it off man
it was tough man I just said in the
passenger's I was in driver seat at
first but I was like clearly I'm not
driving yeah and I walked around and got
in the passenger seat like Hannibal Oh
take me home so I'll tell you our side
[Laughter]
get off stage chill out for a little bit
Lucas brothers did a guest spot on the
show thank you to them and we were just
hanging back and the friend of mine that
when I was filming tagging Atlanta Chloe
it lived she lived across the hall from
me we had some interesting times no not
like that
[Laughter]
so yeah so we heard it we talked for a
while they heard that the last show she
saw of mine was the Loyola show where
the we Oh Mike was cutting our ass so we
talked about that it was funny yeah
hadn't told that story in a while dude
funny to tell it with you know cobble be
with it were their top tony's DJ set got
cut
she was an audience ohs for yeah you
have three different perspectives of
that yeah event in there so you told
that name laughing let's roll out anyway
wait where's person because at this
point absolutely clear down there I say
you know what he's in the car he's in
the car
he's right there he's in he's just
chillin sleeping in a car yeah and then
I go in the pockets and your car keys is
cold out raining yo this [ __ ] is
outside there's gonna be a problem
yeah maybe still in the car no yeah
process of elimination
you were in the car yeah yeah there's
the the when the door open how excited
everybody was to see me yeah yeah
is so crazy I'm like why is everybody so
excited to see me right now no you're
not this process is so weird
like you know what I'm just gonna let
this happen now find out why the morning
yeah yeah well we've talked a lot on
this show I try to talk a little bit
about Isola Mississippi where you grew
up
yeah I know you were born in Chicago in
Chicago but moved
I saw your house gosh three four
something like three or four yes oh yeah
and I sold it until it was time to go to
college right yes stop answering your
questions no yeah no it's weird it's
weird if I'm talking because as we were
looking at you with that mask you know I
feel digesting that but all right Wow
you'll get used to it you know just uh
yeah so just talk about just growing up
and I sold them yeah it was that really
like cash I mean when I think about
country yeah like when people think
country is isola man no traffic lights
yeah police cars no tags on all the cop
becomes the sheriff because just wanted
two cops right yeah yeah one with a
while with their wild dogs
yes stray dogs no these are stray dogs
isn't that what a wild dog is pretty
much it's probably that way you know who
doll it used to be the storage of that
two stores I'm off like a basket
of a litter somewhere and someone's
doorstep just a small small town man but
the crazy thing about it is is that I
saw the population of about 800 people
yes with two Chinese owned stores right
across the street from each other
yeah is it Chinese or they got a Korean
Chinese it's tiny
yeah but the weird it was like a weird
Chinese my my creation that happened and
a lot of end up like settling in
Mississippi for some strange reason I
saw something online about it was a
short dock
yeah that was about that I said that to
get out the Asians moving into
Mississippi in the fifties and sixties
moving into the Delta yeah if eclis were
Solars and open it up a bunch of storage
yeah yeah we like we like cockroaches
man we're like weak weak creep in you
barely see us we'll come scatter around
keep out of trouble
[Laughter]
wow this set up shop here you Scout that
yeah it's just like is that darts and
maps no I'll tell you at least for
Koreans I can speak for Koreans like
because I'm Korean but we're like you
know that's like during the whole LA
riots and [ __ ] like that like when they
were breaking the Korean stores and
Korean news are on top [ __ ] stores
with the guns yes yeah this [ __ ] was
crazy cuz like it's like my uncles and
aunts always had like wig shops and
they'll just like [ __ ] in the hood and
they were just like and but no others
like no other race nobody else wanted to
do that they were scared to go in the
hood but my uncle's my aunt's family was
like giving us money to make yeah we're
gonna do this but you always always
weird when like a place like a soul you
think about the census you know you see
the census in this light yeah
47% black yeah so and so and you see
that small point seven
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I think I don't know when I was brought
down that I saw for the first time
probably five six years old went down
there for a lot of summer yeah as a kid
fun time yeah yeah as a kid running
around plenty of space plenty space you
can play on the street and a street
chase after beagles cuz you know now cuz
of Brian and Terence yeah it also lived
down and Brian
I remember him I one of my most vivid
memories is him getting in a fight with
this other boy we were kids and Brian
won a fight with all kids do you
remember this particular fight it was a
kid they use a dark skip of very red
lips and I just remember all kicks no I
can't is so between that fight and the
last fight I saw Brian and it's probably
a ridiculous number of fights oh yeah
can I just can I just say that that
whoever this kid is
ahead of his time because no one's doing
that now yeah
imagine a fight where you just have to
tie your hands behind your back and only
kick do that be an entertaining ass
fight yeah yeah yeah yeah you know I
would pay I would pay fifty thousand
there's not a lot of things I'd pay
fifty dollars a ticket for but I pay
fifty dollars a ticket to see that I
would you don't feel like the production
will be lured by not being able use the
hands no that's a no-no it's like only
legs you never get to see them could
[ __ ] people love soccer you can't use
your hands on that [ __ ] and that's a yes
but that's the guy come on man we get
into that discussion just want the most
out of my experience about whether it be
in such a small town yeah you know young
kids get into fights you know with each
other but it's such a small town there's
a lot of rematches huh yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
nobody does things the people man you
know if you change weight classes
[Laughter]
somebody get that ass the right way when
you 10 then you 13 and you plus 40
pounds from there yeah wrong it was just
how we [ __ ] about you six months ago
yeah where's the kick yo ass ain't no
they not much happens yeah
easy to hold a crib oh yeah oh yeah dog
woman I went back when Brian had the
grand opening mm-hmm for the palace yeah
and I do it was like during that time
you beat me up we was little and I was
looking at me he's like a firearm into
something that he was just like I just
wasn't feeling his energy issue I'm like
no I
don't remember that [ __ ] though and if I
did I'm sorry because clearly you had to
grow spurt
he was much bigger to be done oh yeah I
could feel but he's tryna he was trying
to run it back I don't know if he was or
not I didn't want it depending on how
you active yeah I feel like what about
now that's good to go
you should have bossed up like that's
what you are
for the rest of your life I gotta go to
work and try to explain that [ __ ] yeah
you know what I do feel that you know
holding on the oh [ __ ] a little bit cuz
this is cat like when I first moved on
to my block around in 1990 or 91 in
Chicago and his cattle on the next block
he had got the best of me one time and I
never forgot that maybe two years ago he
was driving down a block and he saw me
ain't ya oh man you see what you're
doing out there good [ __ ] dog and I said
thanks man
but in my head was that I don't want you
as a person the other side of my ass
will remember that yeah man yeah it's
tough - how long you think that how do
you how long if you guys had to give
that kind of memory and age how long
does that last
it lasts it doesn't go away it's just
how you handle it it progresses and your
maturity and your the way you deal with
it and how you say okay that was we were
kids yeah
or you still hold on that can change and
that could shift with growth and just
how you but don't forget ass-whooping
know you can let up you can do you think
you can make it
[Laughter]
I'm my doubles like a [ __ ] oh I
had an amazing w SIU who is Monty truck
you want that yeah it was bottom on she
tried his sophomore year and his cat he
was known for being drunk and [ __ ]
with people and I knew that - there's
so-and-so he came up to me joking and
drunk I wasn't drunk children and then I
had a juice in my head a Nantucket
nectars apple juice yeah and he says and
he slapped my juice out of my hand and
the glass broke and then I just
straight-up hit him with like what what
is our stories about punching people
have to do with something about a cup
being knocked out of your hand that's
the cup that's - that's one other story
you know only two stories that know
about you fightin socked into the
building cuz then I was thinking oh I
just got into a fight and at the time I
was selling wheat on campus yeah and I
had some weed on me I had like maybe I
don't know maybe 10 15 nickel bags so it
was these friends of Maui's these twin
girls from st. Louis that I know
so I go up to one at a room a hold on it
is for me
[Laughter]
but then you know for the next couple
weeks people like oh [ __ ] you not
specially on campus you know si you're
mostly white schools so the black
community was kind of tight I just you
know if you knew that it was maybe you
were one degree away from yeah anybody
else on this so people oh [ __ ] yeah but
a lot of people that beat him up maybe
two years later there was this place the
barn that was maybe 10 miles 13 miles
away in another town away from
Carbondale people would uh that's where
a lot of the parties were that's what
yeah black promoters were thrown parties
and so you would have if you didn't have
a car you just you know people you a
ride with somebody it's at a barn even
if you didn't even you write with people
you'd even know them that well people
just be nice yeah you rise to the bar
and so this girl she was giving folks
rides to the barn and then either to the
barn from the barn and she happened to
be give an old boy a ride to the barn
you know me and him was a City the barn
wasn't that place was like 5000a was at
50 miles out of town and yeah literally
you're in a barn yeah into like some
woods and [ __ ] and there was a
Confederate flag in there right or for a
while there was an innate that I think
they took it yeah yeah so I always hate
that we never kicked it with each other
at each other schools when we was in
college man yeah yeah how we a make that
happen I want my father's was broke
[ __ ] was not flying like that back
then that it's Mississippi I guess that
would have been a hell of a drive yeah
yeah no I had that gas money yes I do
you know it would have to say right
after I got wanted a refund [ __ ] yeah
yeah refunds so that's how crazy it is
though you Hannibal I was born in 81
pound was 183 and we graduated high
school the same year even though you
know I'm glad you told me that cuz I
always want to talk to somebody about
what it's like to do a great twice but
it feels rousseff but says we cool yeah
it's dope dope
oh I got this is like oh god this is
taking the test and knowing the answers
[Laughter]
the way they had it in our school they
had it broken down like sections in the
class so for example eight one like
eighth grade eighth grade - one those
were the smartest kids yeah and so on
and so I was in like 88
mmm when I was there the first time and
then you went to eight one eight to
eight with a - I was like you're the
student counselors you know raising your
hand yeah I know yeah it was dope man it
was dumb bear plus I was older yeah so
well you have more game yeah I was just
like man I got this [ __ ] figured out I
play football on ass that's when I guess
what I was okay so when you did play
football freshman year yo you crushed my
[ __ ] cuz of that cuz you had a
I change so yeah eighth grade when I
play and then I got to go up could they
help pick like a certain group that play
junior high to play with a high school
team the last couple of games so I got
to do that [ __ ] and he immediately
understood what the weight room was for
quickly and then you know what maybe 15
or maybe turning 14 my freshman year I'm
still small yeah
yes I would still be getting beat up I
didn't start being dope until like my
junior year and we still suck my junior
year duck so yeah I was it was far away
man playing the beatdown sessions and
you just imagine like okay I'm older
that should do not matter a football
yeah that [ __ ] don't matter
well I I've been corner I sold a little
bit more than I usually do we went 2017
yeah went for a high school homecoming
yeah that was for me a mind-blowing
experience yeah yeah going there yeah
cuz yeah it was a wild man what's a
football game with there you know you
got to see maybe some folks you had yeah
yeah yeah
in a few years yeah it was dope here's
what people do sorry
yeah I'm looking at you I'm looking at
you I'm looking and listening I know I
didn't if it's like look towards you
that's you know yeah baby
[Laughter]
so okay people are so used to seeing who
they see yeah that when I was down there
and I saw and belzoni is that
the sort of a bigger city yeah all the
way if you live in Isola you land
belzoni yeah cuz Isola is it that small
ya know school yeah that time zero yes
you go to school here 15 miles away
what so people weren't used to seeing me
cuz they'd like to see in somebody new
in the area is bananas before yeah local
brain net yeah so they'll just instead
of asking me they'll just ask whoever I
was with and standing right there and
I'll just say who is he no no no fancies
like what is that face I don't know that
face my brain can handle that face being
here I didn't know right now you know
who that is
tell me no yeah it's crazy
who's tripped out when we was standing
in front of the player styles of cousin
got the club or whatever
[Laughter]
yeah man shout out the players palace
players palace Isola Mississippi yeah a
local nightlife establishment yeah go
I guess check it out if you're in happen
to be in the area so Lodi solar
Mississippi
I saw the Mississippi I so loved
Mississippi
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my favorite thing about visiting is that
[ __ ] is like the Autobahn in America
around there is no state troopers in
because it's not enough volume put those
resources around people going through
that to make it work somebody post up
with a radar gun it doesn't make sense
first for that area so drive fast it's
like a stretch it may be a good I would
say 30 miles definitely where you can
absolutely safely put that [ __ ] to a
hunted ten yeah and know that everything
like I then it's flat
and it's flat road is straight roads no
curves yeah and you could legit flat
from your foot out in that photo
that [ __ ] is exhilarating because it's
absolutely a safe there's a safe way if
you're gonna do it so yeah if you gonna
do it's the same like you like okay I'm
going 120 and I feel fine yeah I don't
feel like I'm being risky right now you
you weren't worried about maybe a random
pothole or like a possum come jumping
out or some way possible don't die
[Laughter]
possum is local it should notify that's
right
I can't I can't be responsible for the
pot possibly gonna end up under the car
gut that's what it is recipes but the
pothole the road is just is the road to
smooth out it's a highway boom you can
zoom on that [ __ ] that's you at what you
can buy really if you want to test a car
out now you can see what it do own that
my father you feel good it'd be
interesting to see like the percentage
of like vehicle related deaths in our
soul probably like one zero zero zero is
no it's not that's not a yeah that's not
part of the culture
yeah there's no car related [ __ ] and my
father's I probably I wonder if that's
just more of a tourist thing for me too
the way I just like I'm gonna come here
at speed in this local is like yeah do
when when I looked outside and I saw
that charger out there yeah and then we
came in I saw it was you that was like
the third thing that popped in my brain
yeah it's like oh [ __ ] how do we're like
oh we bout to kick it yeah it's like
damn he just like flat in here the
[ __ ] [ __ ] what did you max out it in
that trolley and once here 120 I think I
might have got this I had infinity this
last trip and I fried it was an infinite
abyss but I thought I think I got that
like 130 or something yeah yeah when you
get in that range you start like
steering wheel yeah yeah whoa this is
Wow oh [ __ ] I just burn up what's the
fastest you've cuz I know you rent
Tesla's all the time let's just fastest
you've gone in at I wonder what that
feels like to go the Tesla is because
you don't even realize it until you
that's what I'm saying yeah he doesn't
because it doesn't have the yeah yeah
yeah so it just goes when I've had
rennet tezo's I've been in city stuff so
I've gotten up to a little of a hundred
I think I got it - uh where we just we
just didn't amp where I had one so I got
it up and it gets up there quick - so
you're gonna get it there and bring it
down safely so like one I think I did
105 once and that's it so it's not as
intense in the Tesla no but it's just
smooth though yeah yeah cuz it doesn't
change the performance that much like as
much as a Mustang or a charger or bends
because yes steering wheel thing get you
you know the engine is really working
its net is no engine so it's a different
thing and it's a lighter car because of
that so it's just moving just smooth and
you don't have Pistons in the [ __ ]
engine pump
yeah yeah or maybe you do I don't know I
don't know Tesla's work man oh no God
you want hey I know you listen to this
give me that Tesla doc you know I I was
reading his book and I got so hyped
reading his book and his back I ordered
a test yeah yeah i order that says then
I like put the deposit down and [ __ ] and
in the last day that you could back out
of it I was like what am i doing
yeah don't judge by Tesla out of a book
especially he travels so much yeah
Cobham you were designing it and yeah
yeah yeah you make your own a half or
how much percent no not happy you just
throw it out I think it was done a
couple grand or something okay and yeah
you do that you is is really easy on the
website that [ __ ] is like buying
something it's like ordering delivery
almost like you can design you picked
the [ __ ] you want for your interior all
of that [ __ ] you could do it in my less
than five minutes when you pick in the
feature so it they've really uh
simplified that part of the car buying
process they need to you know what they
need to make though
where that that portable Tesla you mean
just like you get you get off of the
plane and then you just hit a button and
then that your suitcase turns on do I go
to check baggage I crapped my [ __ ] I go
step outside boot is mine that's um
that's very futuristic yet oh that's
next level a futuristic [ __ ] bra George
Jetson but that's I think we'll figure
out teleportation before we figure that
out that sounds more complex yeah that's
one of them expand yeah all the men all
the metal and raw materials like I think
teleportation is more is more near than
that we'll see man I just you know I
just got big ideas that I don't have the
technical ability or intelligence to
execute as you said that they got a bike
like that yeah that's that's what I'm
saying out of I so the technology is
there a bike it doesn't have [ __ ] you
don't put gas in it that's how car
started a bike like a car was a bike
first in the idea like the model was the
Model T that [ __ ] was not that was not a
small car it was no yeah it had to be a
certain size to move just in the thought
process when somebody was looking at a
[ __ ] bike and was like we should make
a car yeah but then you could make the
argument like someone saw a wheel and
said we should make a wagon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I got these for this book got it makes
up what's workable electricity what the
[ __ ] is done Oh
let me tell you about it just get it
laughs what yeah yeah yeah hey can I say
something as a fan of the show
what is that as a fan of the show I want
to say I'm disappointment
oh there's no theremin out here man okay
when is ago I was just look what he was
rapping I was like there is kind of I
wouldn't say it's phased out but is it's
not as efficient of instrument okay on
Amin
and as for travelin because it's so big
okay it's a it takes up a little bit too
much space and you know you weight
capacity but I mean you know what I'm
not making excuses the theremins doping
we can take it back would you you know
portable cars will do for you impulse
production for video anytime you feel
compelled put your hand I don't like
that up with the sound in there
in there I saw the life yeah is this the
most is this gonna be the biggest press
that I won't call it press but this is
most attention I sold as long good
I imagine when YouTube videos are
released it'll be like when the city is
gonna play in the Super Bowl and
everybody gathers and why is it I think
everybody in town or watch this YouTube
clip um 800 800 view of us yeah are we
watching it so to be one view so left
would why you as you started growing up
dick gone through high school yeah what
do you remember the time when you said
to yourself you know I gotta okay this
is I gotta I gotta get out of here
yeah do actually he's crazy you know
such a weird like like it's almost kind
of timeless well not no I won't say
timeless it hasn't evolved on the same
pace as the rest of the country so I
like to go back there now this kind of
or read articles about because they
write articles about that part of the
Delta zoo huh so I think it was like
maybe sports high school maybe about
junior year I was like yo I gotta
[ __ ] get this classroom [ __ ] situated
man like I gotta stop being a dumbass or
some wannabe here which is it's not a
bad place to be it's not the worst place
you can be but for me it was the worst
place so just got my [ __ ] together man
I mean honestly I would have never even
heard of this place if I didn't know
Hannah yeah never like it wouldn't even
existed anywhere I wouldn't probably
don't even see it in an atlas no no I'm
like The Forgotten people actually like
that whole area of Mississippi is like
the people that when people are talking
on TV or whatever like none of that [ __ ]
applies to know they're gonna do [ __ ]
the way they won't yeah the way they
have it's like something's a lot of
southern Illinois is like that yeah yeah
like there's these tiny towns that yeah
they just we got our own rules yes
they've got our own hierarchy yeah yeah
they live like inside of the highway
system so yeah it's not just like a
stopover there's no stopover it's like
if you go in there yes because you know
somebody you ain't get on there for any
reason so that's no that's that this was
double by our soldiers - yeah it's off
the highway yeah yeah oh you know if you
want to go to one part of the state from
the other part you probably passed by so
low you'll drive through Humphreys
County you drive through all that
you know like Greenville Mississippi
everybody knows that you wanna go from
Greenville to Jackson you gotta pass by
Isola so it was kind of people and mr.
catfish capital of the world which is a
weird planning yeah yeah absolutely
though like you do you eat catfish I
love catfish you've had catfish from
there before them
wait what it's catfish capital because
it's just the most catfish come out of
there like you can if you buy a package
of catfish like a box or something if
you look on the back it's private
property dude Wow
yeah the lakes are just stocked know
it's like they form catfish down there
man Wow
so it's like ponds and ponds of tons of
catfish do so like you can see the
process it's not like a dude on a boat
and a fishing pole it's like a hole and
they pulling the fish out of the fish
pond it's crazy and they got like the
where they get the eggs and farmer Mary
just crazy dude yeah I sure I sent you
that uh that menu yeah that it's a place
in Chicago a restaurant called the Delta
mm-hmm I think is owned by a black dude
yes Lee the restaurant called the Delta
and then one of their dishes on there is
the Isola catfish oh yes it's very
specific it's not like when you're in
California you see Chicago style pizza
it was good yes good shout out the Delta
in Chicago on North Avenue goodbye this
was when he played good music in there
too so yeah left
I sold how to what college did you go to
boardies Voorhees worse was that South
Carolina South Carolina how didn't pick
four he's my at the time my brother in
law he went there my sister she because
she did all that she did I got a partial
scholarship to play football at a
community college Oklahoma City itta
Bena college it had been complicated
Mississippi Delta the Mississippi to
come yeah yeah I I'm sorry I thought you
said it had been at college yeah yeah
but uh my I guess ex-brother-in-law went
there Voorhees man and my sister was
just kind of filling out applications
for me and everything and she submitted
that [ __ ] and there's like y'all come
through [ __ ] with us
nice yeah it was dope it was dope it was
perfect for me Joe and how many students
at voice the population of myself
800 students yeah give or take like off
campus you know you got people that live
like on campus is about 800 Wow yeah
that's great from isola to there yeah so
that must've been a culture shock for
you huh no not really
um because I saw Lou I only was around
black people to a black college once a
HBCU so the culture shock was when the
first time I worked with white people do
mm-hmm yeah because there wasn't the
white people I had been exposed to what
do you mean like Mississippi Delta white
people they're always talking about how
is like the time has an effect that that
part of the world yeah so it's not just
in things that you see but it's also
mindsets too so you know when you're in
the Delta you got like a white folks
side of town like like so it's still
like segregation oh yeah absolutely and
then even now you think well I think
what happens what's happened now is is
that cuz just like anywhere most places
money is what really separates people
yeah of course you can't keep me from
over here if I got the Brit yeah so
people started getting the bread and I
sold and start moving to the
white folks are Thailand I don't know
where the hell they go but they go live
somewhere else
mm-hmm yeah so it was like to town the
population is the percentage shift we
sum up the census it's probably shifting
more towards a more predominantly black
community now yeah so then I went from
there to HBCU and then when I graduated
and I was working and been around white
people you know you have this idea about
how they perceive you
you know you carry that it's hard really
it not to be too heavy about it but [ __ ]
no it's not yeah like to kind of abandon
that and just be more open it some
processes yeah of course yeah want to
string me up yeah oh well I get a fair
chance oh this is nice that was Varghese
night it was dope man it was comfortable
well I still got to get that college
experience I got the learn this [ __ ] I
got the Abedin who Percy was a kind of
turned to a frat boy versus yeah I
didn't play supports at all in college
you know I'm saying I hit the [ __ ]
books learn how to drink bear the whole
probably I didn't drinking cup I drink
beer in college ah I didn't drink beer
in class I learned that's what that's
the biggest thing I learned in college
is how to drink beer really yeah dude
I'm like I'm seeing if you remember this
album I didn't used to drink beer mmm
and Hannibal didn't drink beer either
and we got used to get them variety
packs of beer at my crib yeah and we
used to sit in there and get like this
big 24 pack of beer with all these
different types yeah and we're just
sitting there and drink them shits in
place of chaos it well yeah I would
plant okay yeah okay and then was that
come on don't
[Music]
I felt like I had to tell about this
weekend you can see my face right now
your eye look I look like I'm being
honest you like you got something to
hide right now in hot in this room yeah
man you guys yeah you guys take your
[ __ ] 2k very series I used to I don't
I don't I mean last time I came to your
crib man that's the first thing you guys
do is pick up sticks and just go at it I
was tight we retired as [ __ ] no sleep
wheel and me and bozeman right away like
is the rooms here when weakens like nah
get on these sticks your wife got his
food on yes guys just went right in
there that is it is pretty well because
you stay next to a private Airport yeah
so yeah did serious over a decade yeah a
little slack a little benefit of the
doubt now simply because my hand is
right here I want so what it is is that
you know you you you don't have the time
to play as much as I do now
Danny making excuses for you no no no
no-no-no so my expectations are
different man I get the practice more
than you do man I think I gave you
buckets last time yeah actually no I
think I read a few on you on to Cairo we
never say phew I think and listen man
cuz the last time we played play was in
things just the house played in
Charlotte I when I just had a gig there
we got mean we played after the
Charlotte you know tomorrow at the at
the school mmm-hmm oh no no we play
around your birthday
no we didn't cuz we went out somebody
somebody's story screwed up here and I
we went to we plan to Quebec for at the
game boy in Charlotte ah na da we we we
play man cuz we play at the hockey one
to remember but I remember leaving with
a positive attitude
[Laughter]
Hannibal when Hannibal losses in video
games he emotionally shuts down it's
just yeah man I need to see my therapist
[Laughter]
I beat him - oh yeah not two to zero but
two times yeah yeah yeah and I could
just see he's like man I'm destroying
this little from the inside
just a cockiness cuz you come here right
come in good man talking that [ __ ]
dealing when you get down to the stretch
and how do we you over here I'm talking
[ __ ] no oh well you know what it was
with the MBA exam is I usually get you
an MBA exam and so I was I was genuinely
like this is I thought we hit up the NBA
Jam was like oh it is easy my easy work
he thought he had me on job you excited
barbecue chicken go I was like yo I was
like I'm gonna try this NASCAR real
quick he's on the phone he stops the
phone call he's like I don't [ __ ] with
that NASCAR try to play one NBA Jam yeah
and then he won he was like I let's hit
up some NASCAR is what I saw in his fan
base with you know but explosions are
dope yeah crashes too
[Music]
auto-tuned burps - burps he's just not
feeling it now I wanted to remember I
had some other stuff I wanted to talk
about so I wanted to just you know I
took my freestyling and nonsense to the
side cuz there's lots of time for that
alright so here's you what was your
first job because you said you the
culture shock was working with with
white people what was that so when I got
out I came to the city and I started
working Mike yeah I am now I start
working at a group home but then I
started working for this company called
managed care that owned three nursing
homes okay I was doing marketing how
doing sales and marketing there and you
know the dude first of all to do the way
the interview was so [ __ ] crazy dude
is like my boss was like this six for
Russian do like with this crazy big-ass
beard and a turtle net when was some of
the questions so it was like because you
know you you try to do interview prep in
your head
and it's like so Percy let's say you had
a party and you don't know anybody there
in the room what are you gonna do yeah
but you're doing you're interviewing for
sales and marketing job right don't give
a [ __ ] about if you know how to add can
you go in the room with people you don't
know and networking gain friends and
have a drink by yourself and
leave out being a man it was like a
really the job was crazy the job was
crazy but the interview was crazy that's
when I had to get the car yeah it was
for that job it's because I didn't have
a car
what you say is your answer I find the
most powerful person in the room and I
punched him in the face whose store in
the party whose party is no I can't
remember what I said but whatever I said
they was like I we [ __ ] with you they
asked me like two more questions like
that the interview was all of like seven
[ __ ] minutes dude and they was like
all right man you seem dope let's do it
and I was still sitting there like this
is like this other tall white do
pinstripe suit look like a [ __ ]
mobster and the guy with the turtleneck
and he stood up he was six five both of
these models was huge
all right [ __ ] let's go just randomly
apply for jobs person they say tall
people get put in management positions
easier a sense of authority I think
comes with towering over people looking
down on them yeah like I can imagine
that psychological economy I can see
that because even when I meet NBA
players it's all sir yeah respect for
you sir you an MBA but you were your
warm-ups all gay yeah you know your your
interview story reminded me of a way
back I really wanted to work at the Best
Buy yeah just because I wanted to get
that slick discount on your CDs and the
videogame I don't I didn't know I just
was like put the Best Buy I'm gonna make
the best of this yeah so like a slogan
job exactly okay I'm okay
electronics I like electronics all I get
[ __ ] so I go on there and I do the
interview and he was like he was a a
like an older Indian dude yeah but it
was like weird it was like he was he was
like okay I'm looking for someone
specific like you because he's like I
got all these like fussy
dudes that come in here all the time
yeah yeah like they don't know what to
get and they're always asking questions
you know I feel like you might be that
guy again take a bridge that gap and I'm
just like okay so you want me to run the
Asian is that way yeah that's what you
want just ask you run that [ __ ] but yeah
don't make it look like you're trying to
be politically correct about it yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was funny it was funny
the way he worded it - this is goofy is
[ __ ]
but these dudes they just keep asking
questions he's like he's like he's like
well I have to say there there there we
have a large Asian demographic here and
I can't seem to connect with them very
well I don't know maybe you can work
that part of the sales department and
I'm just like okay yeah sure I mean
that's what it takes but I never got the
job because I admitted to him that I
wasn't good at math and that really that
really threw him off because I think he
just yeah how's it at math you think
well you're good at math I'm like no and
he was like well that might be a problem
mm oh yeah I mean at the end of the day
it's like I don't want I didn't want a
job that's gonna require a lot of math -
yeah yeah like my man comes naturally
like if I have to do math my brain just
goes into math mode but like I don't
want to do math what you don't want a
job that has a lot of math but what
about a job wouldn't require a lot of
math I feel like yeah dude on psi off
that
[Music]
to live with the math and I master the
met the left with the master the Masters
of metal of my manthang I missed the
math in a match I met a man at the mess
man math the math the mess - mad - mad
Samantha the map
you big do you do the math - the method
a method of math and amantha - math and
a method of man and the best of the last
the method of mad he had to method a bad
I took some meth in the back and I
messed of the match I got the method of
man I went to CVS and bought the rest of
the man with the man I got the method of
magmatic for man it's a message of math
nine dollars plus four thirteen of the
man's method a math math math math you
know the math that was a good one it's
fun it's like it's like you're like a
superhero you put that mask on and you
turn into a different person
different thoughts man though you might
have to expose the stage to this though
did am a stage elements of danger
involved but their heightened sense that
you have right now adult on stage him in
the zone mmm-hmm that should be crazy
dove you don't even know Tony gone right
now that's not heard of leave yeah [ __ ]
I didn't hear him leave but I saw him
leaves I knew was going south that's a
part of the Heike that's there to hide I
heard the steps
I was about to are you talking so I
didn't want to
interrupt you but I was about to do that
but I didn't want to interrupt all good
yeah man
goddamn yeah Percy in this [ __ ]
on the podcast yet oh yeah time as a
famine this is dope like a fan of the
podcast this is dope to be here man
kickin it mm-hmm laughing this is I
kinda got comfortable I feel comfortable
now yeah yeah just talking [ __ ] you know
I think I think that block and isola
mm-hm
can be built up you think by if the
right businesses are there will people
come from those it's right at those
surrounding town because I sold itself
very small people but a lot of time
45-minute radius yeah absolutely
and that drive those drives aren't
anything cuz it's not a traffic drive
it's just move whatever the time is what
is a 30 minute drive yeah it's actual 30
minutes it's now like just 30 minutes
during this time it's always starting so
I wonder if the right stuff is there
yeah I think we'll draw I think so cuz I
think the first thing about I so like I
said is dope is is that location yeah
it's awesome
yeah you can't like you can't pass you
gotta pass by it right so people pull
into little towns all the time to get
[ __ ] you know so if it was something
like oh I saw look got X or Y I'm on the
way to Jackson let me pop it does Isola
at least have like a target or a Walmart
or some [ __ ] something like that
nothing huh no come on man
800 people target the [ __ ] work it
sorry
[Laughter]
target says they just come out of the
sky I mean I could think of a small
franchise could be there something like
Applebee's that'll be probably destroy
in the area yeah something like that
you know sit down spot with that
withdraw yeah
yes like it was if it's done right
I think just cuz no I guess just knowing
how far people are willing to travel to
get a different experience down there
yeah you know I think it'll work
either way cuz I've gone to Greenville
or you know would drive to Indianola to
get a [ __ ] McDonald's er right Jesus
BBQing you see I'm saying
so it was like so what was the most pop
in this business and I solo
do you remember yeah it's not that it
was like if you want something to eat
you either like you know people have
like mom somebody mama somewhere in the
kitchen cooking yeah I sell them plates
or some [ __ ] like that what are the
plates of chicken or plate so sides and
it's somebody's house and you could yeah
yeah restaurants you're saying now it's
like a gas station that might have a
restaurant they also cooking burgers in
the back at lunchtime some she like that
and that's crazy
yeah yeah like there's crazy Oh somebody
could just check it on a stick gas
station I was really you know help him
Brian with the with the players Palace
the club a little bit but then it from
that I started getting me thinking like
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah could this cuz I think
it's just you know business begins
business so then do you not I mean once
you put something there that draws
people there's something else we come
booked something out for you like oh we
can get spillover yeah from this so I
was are thinking about that like could
we just develop that [ __ ] and
[ __ ] am i is it too much time to do this
hey if you're a real estate person or
investor and you're interested in
investing in a very small town in
Mississippi
I think the margins could be good hit us
up at the handsome Rambler calm with
Isola in the subject line at gmail.com
the Hansen Rambler at gmail.com or just
shoot an Instagram message to the
handsome Rambler Instagram or my
Instagram or Tony trans Instagram with
your ideas for building on Isola yeah
cuz I think I was thinking that like man
I wanna just put a couple hundred grand
in this town yeah I think it could work
yeah it's possible man it's possible I
mean you know talk about Alice about it
who grew up there but she was a kid way
back back in the day and she would say
oh it was a school there and a movie
theater there whoa yeah talk to you my
actually mine they say was a school and
a movie and I think like to hear that
like how the [ __ ] is it not here now
schools in the movies movies in the
school watch the movie to school then I
talked about it at the movies
wait don't talk about in the movies you
talk why you in school you wanted to
move he's in the school you go to school
school the movie oh I went to the movie
and the whole [ __ ] was about school I
went to school the teacher was in there
was groovy they play a movie about
school and school and I went to the
movie was about a school and went to
school they played a movie that [ __ ] was
really cool movies all right all right
Percy why are you only acting like you
ain't got bars man rabbit rabbit for
years and whip that bars dog this is I'm
already way outside my element dog you
want this auto-tuned you want yet you
gotta [ __ ] with the auto tool man you
ain't out do endo element don't I know
you 35 years this is the element turn
this up the years let me say hello
damn bro I haven't seen Hannibal yell at
someone like that in a while you know
what's up ATL in the air B&B is
comfortable this is real nice get a lot
of natural light my father the person
doesn't drove down to South Carolina
just kick in with you that's right like
all last night man we were catching up
just talking [ __ ] together yeah I'm like
man all of this would be perfect past
material yeah yeah yeah yeah us three
get together man
yeah tear it up versus you know used to
drive me to a lot of open mics you're a
kid oh three yeah yeah four is Chicago's
and in the suburbs to some terrible show
yes
no my favorite memory is when you did
that show in Highland Park you want a
competition yeah and I gave that big-ass
check fire there's a big sacrifice
this outdoor powder was it's almost like
eat like how when you hit those jay-z
interviews and he talked about Kanye
West was Kanye West before you knew you
was Kanye West check
they gave him his big-ass check for $500
but they was like also you got a hostess
[ __ ] in the event now it handles
like my hosting costs more than that
yeah but it was really dope you remember
that's it the festival I got a picture I
think I still host yeah that was weird
he was like you I want his contest yeah
five hundred you get the host and now
you try to make it look like it was a
prize to do that that's how that's how
it was structured it probably wasn't
done like that but that's how it felt
yes sometimes people do things with a
certain intention but then like oh this
sucks
yeah I didn't mean you know well I don't
think it was done with mouths no not at
all but if five bucks for hosting them I
got further than 300 Fong on it yeah I
mean three three for our event [ __ ] that
[ __ ] like if they Manuel [ __ ]
like I hate doing weddings my flick has
asked me to like DJ weddings I'm all for
it but it's gonna cost a lot there is
wedding bands get like five stacks yeah
most wedding DJs on average get like two
stacks
these yeah so I go with the band price
yes thanks I'll be there yeah the
destination wedding I'll fly there right
now you go you know but yeah other than
that corny nope you trippin with that
that wedding set that you gotta hit them
with that happy that's a real happy hit
them with that shots on slide five
follow that up with that wobble Mario
hit that goddamn Macarena you hit
another line dad can do it with that
before I let go chip sent your spirit
next thing you know you're a full time
wedding DJ and you got kids and this is
how you support your family like I don't
want to fall into that hole I see people
do it I'm not that guy you know what
unless I'm getting five stack Singh you
should you should just play do it do a
club set out a way but do like play
right Danny Brown because I think that
you know people I think that's just
people have this idea of a wedding DJ
set which it was does happening maybe it
worked but then also you probably could
do some other stuff and people invite
actually it's the video of project pet
performing at a wedding
probably got hella stacks to do it yeah
but his funny seeing him do a chicken
head yeah who's like this way bah bah
project Pat we need project pet at this
travelease my project pan it is wedding
I won't part depends my weight but I
play my wife to be like [ __ ] no you say
is our day do you love me
if you want to merge our souls together
yeah this is part of me baby this and
baby you want the book project Pat you
didn't have look at verse 4 chicken hair
is the I mean if you have enough money
like I honestly believe that Jeff Bezos
could probably get damn near anybody to
play it is at his new wedding yeah yeah
I mean mama if you do gigs if yeah it's
part if part of your income is gigs then
there is a number usually yeah as long
as this I mean if there's as long as
it's now like an evil dictator or some
type of compromising weird situation
Beyonce does gigs she did that wedding
yeah she does gigs it might be a few a
couple million or a million but you can
get Beyonce for a gig I'm sure there's
some weird ones that she's like yeah I'm
ready now
but yeah my favorite gig for the gig
sure I'll put that towards this yeah and
just do a gig and and and you don't use
that use that money to build up I solo
so if you would like to book me or any
gigs and it's not weird the rate is
[Laughter]
great to come you're very I like how
your rate and my rate or $95,000
you're like that's what that's a huge
margin give myself a little bit of room
so yeah what's that you've been you bits
anybody's wedding lately Percy uh yeah I
did uh you do you know sharise's
officiating weddings now do ya yeah man
it just kind of got weird like Julian
Julian got marries my brother yeah so he
got married and they were like oh we can
have Charisse officiate the wedding
she got ordained yes no she's like I
think the whatever the legal standard
you need to officiate the wedding yeah
that component of it gotcha and so uh
then her his friend got married and they
were trying to find somebody and it was
like yo we should just use Charisse the
Charisse charge so she didn't charge the
first two people she realizes a hustle
this is my moment looking in the camera
she didn't charge the first two people
but everybody else will be charged yeah
can't just be if you can't be taking out
time of the day to just officiate
[ __ ] man yeah you got to get
paid for this yeah actually works for
the government and they right now these
[ __ ]
get your gutters here's my question what
are the parameters for officiate meaning
what do you absolutely have to say as
the official yes I make the wedding
legit so to legitimize a wedding do
really
you need like a [ __ ] notary the words
don't mean anything yeah so you as an
official you could really
of damning that genitive that that did
my father that my buddy
yeah tax discounts yeah and sex and kids
and a house and most likely divorce yeah
yeah I pop stamp yep at the queer house
I got a question
oh I just came up with a new brand
what's that
gibberish weddings Oh gibberish weddings
by Hannibal Burres I get I become well I
get a bleep we get official and you hire
me for your wedding and and then I'll
come through this is that bit that
daddy's rang animal might stay all right
well you know hit these bars
[Music]
yeah alright just you want anybody you
want to shout out naw man just thank you
though as a family member but a fan yeah
i compartmentalize it cuz if y'all will
whack I will be like but I'm a consumer
duh yeah cuz you were you were you are
not trying to do it at first you're like
like come on ma'am it's all good but you
know as a person that listen to every
single episode except for the newer ones
I hadn't gotten to him yet yeah like oh
it would be dope to be on the podcast of
a show that I'm a fan of nice thank you
yeah so I took it like that and then
that made a dope cuz just me doing it
the regular late
and it ain't me all right I gotta hear
yourself on your favorite show yeah best
friend Percy Wilson everybody
oh we're not in front of a crowd I'll
clap sleep sleep man's like still on it
sleep man's life by the in it mom and
asleep man's get it double up didn't I
go to sleep fans and I get it all up
melatonin neck get the sleep mask and
I'm sleeping with those [ __ ]
huh eight feet up in this [ __ ] Turner
auto tool up so you can hear my [ __ ]
[Music]